Hey, I'm George Turnbull and I want to be your next employee.
Now, you're asking yourself, "Who is this guy?"
Let me tell you why I'm the man for the job.
I've wanted to work since I was a little kid.
I've got nowhere to go during the day and I'm not in it for the money.
But if you think about it that's exactly why you should pay me more.
To be the best, you need to stay one step ahead of the pack.
Most people run in the morning but I run before bed just to keep my edge.
To be great I think you need to know what it's like to win and lose,...
...and this is why I play chess against myself.
I'm reading the dictionary, typically in a decubital position by the fire.
I feel like these cerebral calisthenics will prevent the deleterious declivity into mental decrepitude.
I'm on the Ds.
Checkmate!
You decadent dastard!
To succeed, you need to look the part and I'm like a chameleon.
I can blend into any situation.
Office parties.
Casual Friday.
Power lunches.
Corporate events. Hey.
If you're still not sure about hiring George Turnbull, just ask yourself this one question.
Where do you see your company in five years?
References available upon request.